tells us
in her extensive very detailed detailed
account
of the first revelation of the Quran to
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
Revelation comes to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam and the prophets in
general
in a number of ways.
Number one, as a vision
while they are asleep and we discussed
this at length before.
Number two,
the angel will come in the form of a
man.
Whether it's a man that he recognizes,
meaning one of the companions, or a man
that no one has ever seen before, he has
never seen before, but he knows that
this is Jirel.
Number three,
which is the most difficult type
difficulty-wise,
which is
how revelation comes to him when the
Quran is being revealed.
And that is as is in Bkari Aisha is well
narrated
that one of the companions asked the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam how does
revelation come to you?
He said,
"Sometimes the angel takes the form of a
man who then speaks to me and I am made
to memorize what he says.
[Silence]
He said, "And sometimes
I hear a desperate clanging or banging
in my ears, and it is the most difficult
type of re revelation that I receive.
And once it is over and released, I will
have been made to see and memorize
what the angel has said to me. And
here a lot of people are confused by the
exact translation or the exact wording
of this narration.
Alus
the dinging or the clang clang
clanging of a bell. That's the exact
translation. A bell. A bell which is
bellshaped with with the thing in the
middle. The bell that comes to mind when
I say that word.
A lot of people think
well if revelation comes to him in the
form of a bell
he hears the sound of a bell
that's not what he said sallallahi
wasallam because in other narrations the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
narrates tells us that the angels
refrain from a party that has a bell
with them.
So for instance, the prophet Sam
says
he said the angels do not accompany a
caravan a caravan that has bells on its
animals. A person may say well how are
these and both narrations are in a sah
in the same book. How are these two
narrations? How do we harmonize them?
And that is that he doesn't hear a bell.
He said
he hears the metallic bang,
that concussion
that a person hears, that very intense
vibration in the ears that a person
hears when iron is striking iron. That
is what he's hearing. He's not hearing a
bell that's a dinging or a dingling
bell. That's not what he said.
was he said
the metallic clanging
that is so
captivating and it fills your hearing
so much that you can't focus on anything
else going on except for that one thing.
Another
form of narration,
the fourth form is that
he will see the angel in his original
form that Allah created him upon and as
far as Jirelam is concerned, he saw him
twice in his original form that Allah
created him in. The fifth and final way
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala reveals
or sends revelation to his prophets and
our prophets specifically is that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala speaks to them
directly.
Now this occurred with the prophet Sam
on
and this occurred on a regular basis
with Misam.
So these are all the ways that
revelation comes to him. However, when
we gather all the narrations that we
have, we don't have any explicit
evidence that he ever received verses of
the Quran in his sleep. Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. He would always receive
the verses of the Quran while he was
awake. Not that if he received verses of
the Quran in his sleep that it would
somehow be less or that it would somehow
invalidate it. No, it's just that
there's no evidence saying that. And all
the evidence and the pattern that we
know from the way that he was taught the
Quran is as Allah subhanahu waala
mentions that
that
descended bearing the Quran upon your
[Arabic recitation]
When she recounted this receiving of the
revelation these first five verses of
surah
mentioned that took the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam to her
cousin her cousin
Ibel and he was her
paternal cousin meaning it was his her
cousin from her father's side from side
and his name was ibal ib abd and he was
a very unique man as we discussed last
night He was bilingual and in some
narrations triilingual meaning that he
spoke and was fluent in Arabic, Hebrew,
and Aramaic.
That not only that, but he was competent
enough to translate
and that he was literate. So he was able
to write that and he was one of the main
figures amongst the Arabs in Mecca that
were able to translate the Tawra into
the Arabic language and able to
translate from Aramaic and from Hebrew
into the Arabic language for the Arabs
to be able to read and comprehend.
However, when she brought the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam to and he
was a man who had become Christian in
Jahyah which was very odd very strange
very rare but he had accepted
Christianity in Jahya and set up set
about upon a journey and a spiritual
journey in his youth and he has a very
extensive story before Islam however
our portion
of his life is regarding his interaction
with the prophet Sam.
When Khadijah brought the prophet
sallallahu alaii wasallam to
war had become very old. He was
extremely old. He was at the end of his
life and he had lost his vision. So he
was no longer able to see. He was a
blind.
And
she brought the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam to try to help to make sense of
what he had experienced in the cave that
night. And she said,
"Listen to what has just happened to
your nephew." Not that he was his
direct nephew, but it's a sign of
respect. Just how you say someone
is you call someone uncle who's not your
actual uncle, you call someone son who's
not your actual son. Here she said
listen to him and listen to what he
had just experienced.
And so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam told him what had occurred what
had happened the visions that this
man came he didn't recognize him he
recited these verses he he had grabbed
him and squeezed him how it scared him
etc. And's response
unwaveringly was
this is the bearer
of news that Allah sent down upon MS
in the Arabic language.
Arab.
[Silence]
So is a is a person who bears a secret
and a message. But it's not just any
message or any secret. It is a good
secret, a bearer of good news
that Allah sent down upon MS. He said,
he said, "I wish that I was a young man
to see the day when your people will
inevitably drive you out of your home."
This could not have been predicted by
any reasonable
reading of the situation.
If you would have asked anyone in Mecca
during his time before he brought
to the people, if you would have asked
anyone in Mecca, who is the last person
in this city
that
the people would turn against? They
would all unanimously say Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam. And for this
reason he was able because of the
respect that he wielded and because of
his high character and high caliber and
because of the because of the esteem
that his people had for him. It was very
usual for him to relieve disputes
amongst tribes.
Even when it comes to bloodshed out of
respect for the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam before Islam, he would
be resorted to to make judgment and
they all trusted him and he was referred
to as
very good referred to as
the truthful and the trustworthy
to the point that if anybody had
anything of value that he wanted to keep
safe,
He would give it to the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam even after he was
a prophet.
Even after he was a prophet and the
people that were fighting against him,
they still kept their valuables with him
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
And why would they keep their valuables
with him? you know for the same
reason that we keep our valuables in a
bank or a safety deposit box, right?
someone to watch over it. Maybe someone
is very wealthy and he's afraid that if
he dies somehow suddenly his children
are going to fight with each other or
they're going to steal from each other's
inheritance, he would keep it with the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. Even after
even after he was a prophet and so the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam was very
taken back by this statement. He said,
he said, "Are they eventually my people,
my people will drive me out?" He said,
he said, "No man has ever brought the
message that you are bearing except that
he is turned against by his people
inevitably."
How does mora know this? Maybe this time
it's different. What does the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam tell us when
we are learning from history?
He said the believer is never bit from
the same hole twice.
And in in one wording
Meaning a believer is never bit from the
same hole or a hole twice.
Meaning not from that same hole nor from
any hole it. They've learned his
lesson. Why? Because one of our core
beliefs
and you will never find that the sunnah
of Allah changes doesn't change
suddenly. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
not spontaneous with his sunnah. He
doesn't just change things suddenly. He
subhanahu wa ta'ala is consistent
and that goes hand in hand with justice
subhanahu wa ta'ala and so this is
the this is the way of people and human
beings and fighting against prophets but
not only that but knew this because of
something else and that is that every
prophet gets an enemy.
Everyone, not just every messenger,
but every prophet,
every man who has received revelation is
appointed at least one enemy.
Subhanah.
And so every person who is receives
revelation
receives what? An enemy. But notice that
not every prophet gets a friend.
You don't need
friends
in order to be upon the truth. It is not
absolutely critical
to being upon the path of guidance to
have a companion. But it is absolutely
critical to have what? An enemy.
Why? That sounds counterintuitive. No,
you have to have something to struggle
against. It is part of what completes
your identity. We are not just
identified by our
morals and what we uphold. We're also
identified by what? Our enemies.
[Silence]
He says the as the Arab poet says
that
the opposite brings out the best of its
opposite. Right? And and this was
actually in a line of poetry describing
his describing his love, his crush,
right? So he's saying
[Silence]
he says in his poetry that her face is
very very white and her hair is very
very black. her face. He's he's
describing his his you know his
romantic interest in this line of
poetry and he's describing he's saying
her hair is black the dark night
and her face is as white as a full moon.
Two opposites when they come together
they look perfect together in contrast
and opposites bring out the best of each
other. That is why prophets need enemies
and followers of prophets need enemies
but they don't necessarily need
companions. We will pick this up
inshallah tomorrow tomorrow evening and
finish up this narration.